Günther Jauch one of the best-known
moving image people that ever existed in
Germany but just on TV
now for the first time here on youtube
however only auditory to only via audio
I've just been at home in Potsdam and there
were no video
recordings but there were sound recordings but they have it  in itself
and there is now a
bit of a corona overhang here we are sitting
here is holy st yes and i am
happy that we can do it now i am happy
too hello hello so i had
to explain before talks today
not the typical guest for this
podcast  but of course extremely
interesting a lot of listeners i think you
know them
as well as you can say so inventory
of the federal republic but
maybe the beginners don't know
exactly very briefly it started with radio
and also very early on with thomas gottschalk
right yes i have my high school diploma in
berlin and then I just wanted to get
out
or do nothing at first to
recover from the stress on m  one parent not
so funny
please at least start some degree then i
applied for law and
rejoiced because my Abitur grade was so bad
that i was initially rejected
numerus clausus and then, to my
deep regret, was given a second place and
then actually have  I studied law for a semester
at the Free University in
Berlin and then I passed the
entrance examination for a German school of
journalism in Munich
and then
I entered Munich
which led to the fact that i got an answer from bavarian radio at the age of 20
to be employed permanently in the
sports department radio wasn't super sport i was
interested i
liked doing it but then it developed
further then after
two years i wanted to do something up to date i can do something up to date
in the so-called time un  d
did a lot there and during that time
also got to know thomas gottschalk,
who at the time started
a kind of acoustic revolution as far as radio was concerned, he
made radio completely different from what
had been going on for decades before, you had
nothing serious, you didn’t
announce anything, nothing paper it  more
but that was
living life for the ears
and i thought that was great and since then we've been
good friends but it must have been along
the way that you both
always referred to each other a little
bit, it kind of created a
very special situation
have taunted everyone have on the same
station were that is a historical
moment yes well that just came from there was
the funny entertainment and i was the
boring information uncle and
we used these two poles very
extremely that he explained to me what was going on in
the dallas and  denver episodes
on tv happened last night
which didn't bother me i  interested and so i
explained to him the basics of
russian foreign policy and
we always
went back
and forth between these poles and people liked that a lot it
was funny back then when i hear it now i think
some of them recorded it all
it's not so
funny anymore but that's probably
most people hearing the pictures or acoustic
recordings from before that
doesn't seem so exotic anymore
and what was the
first real acceleration of your
career, so to speak, yes the acceleration was
certainly the youth show in the
bavarian television live from
alabama
there was after me yes when i di lorenzo and
then
the woman maischberger then
took over before me on 11
amelie fried was with me and so it
always went back and forth then there was an
acceleration current gym  in
zdf then there was an acceleration
gottschalk took over betting that
1982 and gave  to me the show na
something like that for me na see you was called
on zdf from funny colorful
entertainment show yes and
that then developed further and further in 1990
then came
the opportunity to go to rtl
I think I should also do the
entertainment clown and I
said  no i don't want
that i would only switch to rtl if i could do such
an
entertaining information show
and then i came up with the concept
of sterntv and
together with others and then
suddenly it was exactly
this lucky bag of acoustic and and and
and TV lucky bag  also the one
that people liked and that has worked great
now for more than 30 how long
do you need something and how long do you have to watch TV
before you
get this house everyone can tell how it
used to be years under construction or  I
'm already there after 23 years.
Of course, it was relatively easy at the beginning
because there was no private TV at all
there was also no private radio when
i started that means people
inevitably knew me that also
led to funny situations when i was
at the baker’s somewhere in
munich and i ordered my rolls or rather
rolls then the saleswoman supported
her and said to her  get to know someone from somewhere
said yes it could be that
we somehow have your voice that sounds familiar to
me and then i said yes
i am the one who in the morning
you always get higher at bayern3 imagined my boys
hans-werner completely
differently, like 60 60 years  with gray
temples there's no
such thing as watching that's always the culprit in the morning and
that's why it was really good that I
started with radio because I've
always been an editor for school
newspapers, except for
many years and they
probably didn't really
buy me serious television work  I actually
didn't start watching TV until I was about
30  then it went so slowly yes
and that's why it was easy to develop as a
television dinosaur that i am there
now
there was gottschalk then later
harald schmidt then there was me and
then all the really old-timers like rudi
carrell also got together  dem kulenkampff etc. i
believe that such people are also losing their
careers at the moment due to the overdue
fragmentation of the television landscape and
that if they can unite 5 percent of the users somewhere, they are
basically a superstar
that is why such
careers may no longer be possible  are possible
what was then maybe the format what
best contributed to your career at stern tv at the
end of a length, so to speak, and then millionaire
in principle stern tv and the area of
ainment clearly who wants
to be a millionaire stern tv in an absolute class
c for me very much
the five years in which i did the talk in the
ard were important after that  the crime scene
that was very interesting for me and the
fascinating years were very
exhausting always a struggle
within the ard as to what you could do
and in the end i gave it
up because i didn't have the
journalistic freedom that
was actually discussed with me
beforehand and i have  I'm the kind of person who
says if if if it's no longer
fun and if you're restricted, above
all in terms of
journalistic independence, then it's
better not to do it, but it was
unusual that I only did it for five
years, I usually do
ten 15 20  or also or even more than
20 years the secret recipe is
consistency yes that's just the way it is and in the
entertainment
sector it's more who wants to be a millionaire actually hit
like that i didn't think it was
possible myself the ratings have of
course gotten lower now
but i say  let's face it, we're still floating
very solidly far above the
clouds  since we
actually started out in space
i had a year ago
every show and it came three times a
week had an average of ten million
viewers that was that's absurd
that can't be done today with
this fragmented media landscape
but it worked back then  just now and when
did wirtschaftshof come the moment when you had
the
opportunity to produce your own program for the first time because my
understanding is of tv then it will also
be lucrative again
yes on the one hand yes on the other hand also more
risky i never wanted to become a producer
and have always shied away from it like  the
devil the holy water for one
simple reason i always just wanted to be
responsible for what i say in front of
the camera or on the radio do
moderate
tell narrate practice but i never wanted to be
responsible for it the sound was
somehow not right the
lighting is poor what do you have
because there for strange
camera settings etc that
first of all it didn't interest me and
secondly i didn't want to be
responsible for it either but then it happened
that
the owner of
the production company made stern tv
it was essentially green
and year
that they had ever higher profit
expectations what the production of these  Consignment was
concerned,
which we also complied with and I
always thought, well, then everyone will be
happy that the profits are growing and leave
you alone, but I
learned for the first time that the request then became
very clear, please bring
50 next year  percent
more and if you brought the need we
please win 70
more next year and
at some point i didn’t find that so funny anymore, above
all because it went to the substance of the
show the more you win you always
have to deliver the less money
you can  put it in your product, it
frustrates you at some point when
they say we can make one
properly researching the matter but we no longer have the
money to send the camera team to
india again but i wanted to send it
to india so
at some point i said people either i will
produce it from now
i said after ten years or after new
year 1990 find it  the show went
loos what has 99 i said people
there is only one chance that i will
stay on as moderator
i will create a lot of excitement among the owners in the future
because they feared that
i was insanely
hyped on the new market in 2000 with
highs on the stock exchanges that  i sold the
company
immediately for what was then called 500
million deutschmarks that would have been the equivalent of
250 million euros would have brought the scales
would bring it to the
stock exchange and sold it that
probably would
have been possible at the time but it wasn’t my intention at all
and i did  I said people how
can I take away your
worries by having at least 25.1 percent d  he kept the
company i said you are
very welcome to do it but please only for a maximum of
three years then you have to
pay us extra money if we let
you out of it say yes i will do it and then
it will take another three years then
the company will belong to me  quite and i had
it for almost 20 years until i
actually sold it but that
's the area where it's attractive
so if you're now, so to speak, as a
hired moderator against a
fee what makes it not
bad but if you then pay  the
whole thing about the whole production
then is normally more exciting yes
it is financially more exciting but of course it is
also more laborious and involves
considerable risks you are
made responsible for everything you have
to take care of everything and what is the most
important thing is you have it was like that with
us  the responsibility for a strongly
growing company that in the end actually has
permanent employees and i think more than 200
all in all with all events if it
even
reached 50 60 million sales i
could read up on that a
little less but so in the 3 and
those are not advertising sales are yes because
the the money the broadcasters
pay for pitch his concept  or you
are assigned to there you
really get it you have to try
to become independent at the beginning it was so
that 100 percent of our
company’s program was moderated by me very
dangerous thing total dependence
on me if i had fallen over
the company would have been done for which
i  you said very early on that you must
please become independent of my own
person, otherwise it will always be a
very fragile matter and then
the percentage of
programs that had nothing to do with me as the
moderator has actually grown so much
that i think i still will in the
end  I moderated another ten percent of the show
and, interestingly
enough, who wants to be a millionaire did I  never got the
production order because i
can say that's actually from an
entrepreneurial point of view that would be a
dream because i say yes
everyone will probably earn billions
or millions 104 millions over the
years has just where they
really had leverage says people
want that  now also in which my yes
still have one of my company it
was no longer yes the endemol sham i
believe you that makes yes i can
hardly believe it when the court has that
is the way it is and
i think they have the pan-european from the start  I even
had a license and
I could never shake that, I accepted that, like
sun and rain, you could have called
it something else, then to other colors and who wants to be a millionaire or
somehow, like 30 he would have gone,
but yes, I know that  Basically,
this classic quiz genre is
not protected as a trademark. Everyone can ask
questions and then any
prizes or  advertise prizes there are
now dozens of the products mentioned
but I didn't want to do
that as much as I never wanted to take
advantage of the very last chance that the
very last euro was gone. I
can only recommend it to anyone if you
can afford it with a certain
equanimity  to work with a certain
generosity with a certain
nonchalance
also in economic
life without ever becoming careless of
course never squander the money but
if at some point you
start haggling whether every third cup of coffee
in the company is provided
by the employer or you
simply say people coffee and  water is
free with us and maybe with coke and
orange juice, under certain circumstances that can
contribute more to satisfaction than if you call yourself
euros more a month half-time how is
the production for the
visit or how you operate today
you do 10 15  20 percent return
or rather 3 or wii impressions
before  so i don't have the
production company anymore but are of
course for it i work for them
but get my
presenter he should generally be from
the station so the
company has nothing to do with it except that they used to
produce it was the trick
much better there they were always very
nice
very nice double-digit double-
digit percentage range
and then that's because the broadcasters
have saved more and more the
control also gained the upper hand
more and more after the calculations
you have eight meters of camera cable there
I have there we have there  comparable
productions that come out four meters and
fifty cables and so it is
actually calculated more and more,
more and more calculated down everyone then
passes the pressure on to
the next
service provider and in that respect it is
not as adequate as it used to be for a long time
but
still has now  so cheeky a party
company that you can see in the media or
knows the digital branch because she just took
axel springer off the stock exchange
he has another
project in germany different
production companies are being bought
together including her
former one and u can only
imagine 15 sales that will
already have them  already paid fairly
because it was
probably quite good get children they
sold it anyway because the
offer i would be so good or because
they thought
watching tv that will also be difficult in the
next few years so i'm also happy
if someone takes over now
well the real reason was
i have to see how old i
am i will be 64 in a few months
if you have a company like
that, especially in a media landscape
that is
changing so dramatically you have to think ahead i would say
five and six years  what
is the position of the company then what does it
produce where is the trend going and am
i still the right person  ige so then i am
the head of the company of the 70 year old
i am the one who says people we
have to be innovative insofar as we
now only do this or that,
that we are no longer
primarily there in linear television
but set up digitally or  the
say no
content is needed everywhere it
doesn't matter at all whether it
takes place on digital platforms or on
classic television that
we focus on these are all very
important decisions plus the
responsibility for 150 people i
asked myself can't that as
for  example 70-year-old and the second
question i want that too and the third
question you ask yourself
first is well who could follow me afterwards
and in case of doubt that would have been
one of my daughters
but none of them is interested in
tv
management buy  out was out of the question
because no one was interested in
it and probably n too  nothing could
have
been done so that in fact the
only thing left was the sale and that
was the real
reason, which I am also very happy about in retrospect,
after
two years of negotiation it was very
laborious so the due diligence so where was
such a  It
took a very long time to
examine the company and kkr is also a company that does not
turn over every pebble but literally every
grain of sand
and which then also found
some comma errors in
some old contracts for
me, so first of all they never interested me
and secondly they never affected
me but  they are already
on the road very often
and we apparently
got through it quite well and then we came to an
agreement in the end the timing couldn't have been
better that the economy
is doing well, of
course you couldn't have known that at all at the time and what's more
, our company  at the
moment still
without sacrificing distance  r produces
so we haven’t had a format
failure yet nothing important has been
postponed so the company is
currently actually as
efficient as it was almost
not true when I was there so the order
situation looks very good it’s because the company’s customer portfolio is
like that  that only the classic
broadcasters there are now also these
large digital platforms because of which
i think the transaction was also
made we wanted in the end to have something that
they could sell amazon to netflix and 19
so of course there is
also a youtube format that we  doing the
digital area
has been greatly expanded and upgraded in everything that has to do with stern tv
that that is certainly
true and then i think it
can be done more easily without me and in that respect
i didn’t do it i do
n’t regret it at all  all in all, the
television landscape
has become more difficult in terms of production, which could be
related  no one has been with corona
before but i have to say a very
old companion of yours has now
bought something with the kicker money
fred kogel thing i have
known for over 30 years and
also from that time bavarian radio
and in that
respect we have  never
lost sight of us and
that was it was a very fair
story how we slowly got
closer and then cleaned up at the end it
just
sort of sounded through that you the digital
topics are not your topics are
maybe age-related but it
now there is also frank elstner who is
suddenly a few years older
doing the youtube show and there are
also other examples as a gamer but
isn't it so areas of interest no
desire to make netflix for youtube so to speak that can
also be right  be good so there are the
leaves men made crazy is
netflix format you will certainly have
seen yes  clear that there
are definitely possibilities
my colleague kerner does it
for magento as for magento tv just the
possibility would exist surely you have to think about it
for me
personally you just have to see
that there is still a lot more to do
than where I used to be  I actually
watched a lot more TV than
today because I've had a small farm for ten years
that requires a lot of work and
and where I always
have to commute a good 700 kilometers one way and for
a few months I've had a
restaurant in Potsdam  and so especially
an agriculture and restaurant,
not only in Corona times it is a
real challenge, but now of
course even more so and I
just have so much to do that I do
n't actively apply for new tasks now
and landscape agriculture
or viticulture that
I think they do that, but that can really be
read up on from family
grü  nd above all, yes, it is so
that
it was a good founded by my
great, great, great, great grandfather who,
as the second mayor of the city
of trier, signed karl marx’s birth certificate
and that was a
good then my great uncle was there me
as a child there was a lot and then the
great-uncle died and then 30 years
later the great-aunt also died and then because
they had no children it went well to a
niece from their family and so it was
from the direct family for the first time in 200 years
line out
and 15 years later i
heard rumors that it sold well it should be sold
i haven't been there for 40
years and
then said man he doesn't
maybe something and my wife also
said you'll like it then
we'll be there  went there contacted the owners
they always
snuck around for two years they didn't
actually want to sell it and i
wanted to own it  I haven’t bought it yet because
I had so much to do myself and
then we reached an agreement after two years
and we’ve been making very nice riesling for ten years
now
yes and how big is
the company that has 16 hectares of
vineyards we have six employees
and produce about a hundred thousand bottles
a year here ok but the
hot guys have to do with branding everyone
said i should i should that was a
good one then both of them are good they too  name
but it has the name of my grandmother
the
gis from otto grafen that means if
my grandmother
had married me a profane gentleman jauch i would
run through the fans today as günther from otto graf and in this
respect everyone is probably logical from a
marketing point of view  5 now there
is at least the günther jauch edition
or something like that but you
have that relatively z  made unreserved so
i wanted to keep the tradition of this
winery i wanted to keep there is
a günther jauch edition actually
in the discount area but the wine
actually has nothing to do with our wine
, it is an edition that
we created together with our cellar master
where we also exclusively
only use german wines but
actually no grapes from our
good we would be within less than
a day if we were to market the choice of
our good then we will be
sold out and that is not the point to
say because günther jauch pulls so strongly
no because simply the distribution
a completely different one is if you
can say here that the two are available
at
aldi the distribution possibilities are
simply so gigantic that for such a
small family winery which would not fit at all
with the line that is being
driven at the discounter in this
case during  we just
get lost if you ra  would like to get us
whether a person works in the field of digital
economy then you would
only have to say asama, for example, and if these people
then know asana then you know they
work in the digital field
because asamoah is a very well
-known platform through which projects and teams
are currently being managed  in times of the
home office it is totally relevant that you do
n’t meet anyone and don’t talk about everything
you have to have a platform over
which the work processes are structured
where everyone can enter progress and
so groups were able to
collaborate and
exchange ideas without constantly
talking and  somehow keeping your own
notes as anna is
one of the leading tools in the world not
for nothing recent companies like
viessmann beiersdorf zdf red bull many other
asama we in the podcast
team also use as anna to manage the
various tasks
together, so to speak  who
has never heard of this  t that of
course in times like these as anna is
really almost essential for survival
so asana dot
com but the brand is still
strong so if you talk a bit about the brand
you are now a like
i recently read the most credible
testing as credible  testino or
or a person's brand in germany people's
brand of the year
somehow you ca
n't deny that it's just
incredibly valuable
I don't know but for me
it's more or less a virtual value of course
if the people  from our
winery von othegraven know that he's
actually behind it
there are maybe a few who say
i'm curious i'll try it
or who say if their wine does it
then it will be reasonable but
there are also quite a few who,
especially with so  a product like wine
say now the one who makes himself
important now the one from the television has himself
also added a winery like
sting or angelina jolie or brad pitt
in france and i prefer to support
a poor hunchbacked winegrower
who needs it the number of people
who think like that is actually quite
large so that i would now
say that my name in particular
as far as the winery is concerned,
maybe 20 percent help
is 20 percent on the brakes and
you end up back at plus minus zero in the
end but
there is generally an interesting
history with you and advertising so there
were years when you did advertising
even today i tried to find out
in my circle of colleagues
no one knows exactly what
all they actually gave to that
moment like haribo and gottschalk or
dear and ripped guiza there was
apparently somehow in the case cleverly
chosen many short defend that
nobody  really could bind them permanently
and then at some point they
said and that's enough m
I don't advertise at all now, yes, that was
actually the case,
but I've already
completed at least three years and then often
extended it again for another three years,
around six years, but it's
actually when nobody cares
about it anymore  reminds me after the years
it's really good for me personally for the
product maybe not like that and
then I actually
said almost ten years ago I said
now it's good
and now let's leave it at that
meanwhile I would be there what would I be there
probably not so anymore,
yes
, i should say, meanwhile,
i wouldn't be so disgusting anymore and
could even
imagine that if the product
fits and if the conditions fit,
but i'm really not
chasing after an advertising contract anymore, but what
what does it cost you indirectly for a year without
advertising probably if
you think about what you would
get probably sc  hon millions yes
yes that is certainly significant
but
that doesn't matter look if you can
admit
to yourself or
be happy about the fact that you are
economically independent then
you
can yes then you can
think endlessly about what else I could do about
to have more and
to outperform my neighbors and there a
competitor and in the end you
only see i don't know bill gates and
jeff bezos in front of
you i actually think that's
relatively
safe relatively blossom then there to set more and
more goals  and if
you can tell me, really,
not that terribly much can happen to me and i
have a nice life and above
all i can live as i want to
then other things come to the
fore i have often met people
who
i then went with
drove around somewhere in a small car said
yes and where is your porsche
then I said no  he doesn't have a porsche
or ferrari i don't have a
ferrari either from the outside it's
often suggested that you should live like
this and also show
what you have financially, for example
, and i don't think that's a good approach at all,
everyone should be like that
live as he would like, just like there are some
apprentices who save some
Porsche from their mouths and
live in the car, so to speak, and then
save the room for it because that is what they
would like to do and they would like to see
their realization in it,
but would like to do it the other way around  I'm not
forced to speed across
the country with the lamborghini, but
actually to lead the life
that I would like to. That
certainly doesn't happen in a
two-room apartment in the city, but it's
certainly not characterized by a castle-like
property
she reads then there were
still a few adverts sweet at the time when she did that
advertisment
nd you once said something like that which is
another advertising sin but i throw a
sin in one of the hundred thousand
articles could give it to me so i
don't get it anymore so i'm
real advertising sin my goodness
telekom is really not advertising
sin there was only the mail order company
quelle
then there was
krombacher then there was
everything i can't even
put it together anymore but i've seen crazy sins
there are you actually interested from time to time
or have contacts with
this new startup scene where people set up
companies  that's also working with
celebrities is very
pronounced there or do you have the job
model none in principle no points of
contact there are of course
twice a week people who drive
more present ideas in which
I should then participate for 500,000
euros but
that  everything is not very attractive and I
have never heard of the corresponding ideas
again, ok so
auc  h no interest at all investing money again
also working with professionals
something like that there are some in the usa who say
okay i'm having fun too there is
this tv show is loosening the case and something like that
is a bigger topic clothes
in society that could be  very young
yes at the moment actually
not and if you also see
that
in the lion's den it is of course
often enough that it was
recorded weeks in advance
then the lions sit there and think about
where they can pick up a product  where
basically
the profit is already
priced in it because they can accommodate it in time
at lidl lidl
then advertises with from the seen yesterday at the
lion cave and today these
clothespins are already with us and and
then something like that inevitably works but
I don’t think so either
so class exciting ok in general
but what social media as a channel if
you look at instagram there is no
günther jauch there gi  bt there is a whole
series of günther jauch no
real knights as well there are also i
believe over 20 30 günther jauch
profile and also with your photo but
none that seems to be official
part of the platform use it like that
yes there is  also already too many
fake accounts on facebook
instagram you are also right twitter
i observe that from time to time and
as long as there is no swindling
apropos swindling i will
come back to this for months there have
been highly criminal
people who
[music]
try someone in bitcoin  systems to
lure and they advertise, for example, with
planks and with me and with people from
who wants
to be a millionaire and you should dani and and I are put
phrases in my mouth that I
would have committed myself to it and they are
absolute scammers
you have to pay at least 250 euros
people have written to me
that 70,000 euros their entire
assets what they have
saved up for old age h  but then i lost i
tried from the start
with a big law firm in berlin
to
counteract this and also to find out where the people
are sitting they
probably bet
in madrid i already
paid four-figure court fees so that they could be sued in
some way it is
incredibly difficult  to put a stop to this this dirt
and this criminal
these criminals
and i am now also in
talks with e.g. facebook and google
because of course it
takes place on the platforms and because i have a
huge interest in this
scam finally stopping the platform
can now tell me that it
is  want to take care of it more but
that's a very bitter story
as far as social media is concerned, it's
actually still a question of time for
me I can also see that from my
children that it takes an
awful lot of time as a consumer
who always said how many how many
people do you follow
e  there are about 150 who
say that everyone tells me if you give 150 there
are at least 250 who you follow
and if you then add up
what that means for the whole day and
if you then say you also want to play these
channels yourself
active then i don't even know where i should get
the appropriate time my
colleague
gottschalk opened a
twitter account with greater success was also
very praised for it but how it starts
etc i think it made a good
year had over 100,000 followers and
has  then gave it up because he said i
was out and about all day
with the thought in my head what do i
have to
start now post photos so as not
to have to admit to myself at the end of the day
either nothing happened
or i have nothing to do with the rest of the world
passed on so when we were eating at some point he
said you could
just take a quick picture,
well, we can do that somehow ma  chen
but then what then leaves you and
partly also embarrassing and I also want to
say quite honestly so people who then
others with every trifle
bermann so photograph the famous breakfast
and today I'm going to
eat a doner kebab again and
here is a giant snake  the
business but that used to be
different so basically bothering
people with their own everyday life in such a
way
that i find that incredibly tedious and
i don't want to either so
you can see the power that is
emerging there with kim kardashian and how  they
all mean the whole fun of it
range i can see that clearly i also
see that as far as business things are concerned
instagram is a real turbo that’s
true i also think that
if you have a company,
for example if it’s something  As far as wine is concerned
, digitization is slowly playing
a very
important role, much too late. You'll come up with
something  But I have to know, especially as
far as I am concerned as a person and as a brand,
as you called it, my
interest is simply very limited. I
also have no ambition at all
to write my autobiography. I would
certainly end
up at the top of the bestseller lists for a year because that
in general it is always self-
perpetuating but i don't have this
urgent need to communicate but
the offers will probably be in series yes of
course every publisher thinks that's chic
and we then also make ten cost
riders and authors available but
i
have no reason to do so and
i would be there  myself are
bored telling other third parties about my life
yes so is economically
very clever or also i think
somehow interested above all things
how is your view of this
digital economic world where everyone says
we are dominated by american
platforms they are sometimes
worth a hundred times more  as the largest
eng  I don't know that the dax companies are
still somehow worth about as much
as google doesn't even
make them because the business
journalist or expert also cares or
gets them again I don't want to say but of course I've been seeing it
with great
interest in the last few days
hello fresh has become more valuable
than air in absolute terms and that's of
course
interesting to see how even
modules like warren buffett
used to say i
only invest in
mcdonald's razor blades and everything you
touch and what i above all
can understand and what what is apple what
is google what is it amazon he has
always kept his distance and in the
meantime with his more than 90
years he has
been taught a lesson has become smarter and has
changed his behavior accordingly
insofar i see
all this
with great interest also the
turbulence eg around a company like
wirecard very
interesting
interesting business model what
they have and how they are in focus at the same time
that supposedly the bookkeeping is not supposed to
be so perfect they then
collapse accordingly from the course he
then there are hedge funds that
bet against then it goes up again rapidly
so find things like that  I'm also
very interesting to see who is
I would be which company which
business model is possibly only
a temporary phenomenon and will
eventually become completely uninteresting
again was interesting for me for the first time
studivz I don't know
who else reminds you more clearly that it's
also practical  the student haller
dream that i i think i
thought for 800 million 80 80 what i sold
today too much that brings for 80 million
as firewood
i was closed a year and a half or two years
ago the last card was deleted
so those are already  interesting
things i d  ie I also really follow with
pleasure and mood but not a
shareholder
[music]
so on google on facebook on amazon
partly partly already entry
exit I often left too early then
again such a
classic you have to put it in the
portfolio  on the other hand, if you see
that amazon i think you earned a bit of
money at some point but
otherwise just growing growing
growing then you have lunch with the
cloud where of course good money is
even weirder of course basically
spotify well never a dollar
never earned and our 25
billion value
apparently and on the other hand
who invests in a company that
never earns anything and where you
actually except when this
hype goes on and on and maybe
then develops into a bubble then
at some point it crashes
are the interesting
questions you ask yourself specifically
what what  companies that are based on digital
ideas questions that one constantly
asks oneself okay that comes from a
certain distance a certain slight
astonishment
well actually not because of
course stock exchanges quite often
live from hopes from ideas from the assumption
that something will develop great
but even if  you take something
comprehensible like now in
the corona crisis,
which is the largest
manufacturer of respiratory protection
from respiratory equipment is drägerwerk in lübeck,
which of course inevitably must have
almost doubled its stock market price in the crisis
, but then that’s how it works
within a day of the costs again
for around ten  percentage and more
collapses of course these are all
interesting things where you already notice
that the leverage is so
big that it can hardly have anything to do with the
healthy business development behind it
make such investments yourself there
is a team that does it, so to speak  in which helps
a  So I do quite a lot myself
but I also have
a classic bank that lends people out
, it's not that
easy, a normal bank that takes
care of it, but I'm actually able
to talk to them, but I don't have to worry about
the German travel  there is an economy now,
before the corona crisis, there was
maybe even more now, but
should the question of the connection in
digital times
be clear, of course, the german economy has
always been steel in the classic way,
and cars, for example, chemicals, of course
, so too,
especially the paradigm shift  in
the car industry and as far as all the
suppliers are concerned who are involved in
how that is managed, it is of course
an interesting question, just like
you saw with tesla, on the other hand,
that they also had insane fluctuations
that he noticed had production problems up to the point where
it
no longer works  and then this small
volume model should come out d
somehow you didn't get it right at all
and then you see the processes
at vw at bmw at daimler benz are these
dinosaurs are they really are these
supertankers who are able
to steer in such a way that they then basically do that with the same
power  be able to build and secure the car of the
future or the mobility of the future of course
the questions i find i find it
interesting do you have an answer as to how
the wies will evaluate i don’t
have you ever met any of the makers i.e. receive
crimes
or like broadcasts elon musk or  bee
gees or whoever
no, i had dealings with bill gates a
few times and
actually know most
of the dax board members, i.e. the CEOs
or the
spokesman for the companies i know
quite well private contacts or
both as well as bill gates  the
dessert still he would have even predicted the
crown story more or less
a few j ago  ahren well
that was impressive but
actually not so he is
relatively new in personal conversation what
bores him terribly
was at least for years when he was addressed as the
richest person in the world
that is of course always a good
question and the fact that he deals with
the  foundation has basically plunged into completely different
things
, namely, for example
, eradicating and eradicating any contagious diseases in the world
is of
course super interesting today of all days, which has
also been the case in recent years, even though it
has also specifically targeted certain
countries, which I did  what the
bill gates foundation
finds very interesting is that they calculate very
coolly which funds we can use where
we can achieve the greatest effect
and not at all this pity number
eight the poor children and we have to
send them a couple of sandwiches now  that
that wasn't
really the point  but
internet wlan philanthropy is
understood entrepreneurially that is
not very interesting
currently it is mainly about
staying at home and unsurprisingly
these are also the times of the
streaming platform
maybe quite good to know that
vodafone also has its own streaming
platform which is called the ktv logically
vodafone he is the giga company so
giga tv will be there are offers for parents
as well as for children children can and can
learn english there can watch asterix there can watch
fix and foxi there
all these things but there are also the latest
movies there the invisible m a
spider man  than say that somehow a
colorful package who
wants to try it all would like to take a
look vodafone.de stream giga tv exactly the
duel over which you can
start streaming vodafone.de stream giga tv uses so
easy if and at vodafone since
why is there also a  bit stream
[music]
mine are also very much that can also
talk about it s  rather say
philanthropic committed in the same
direction or or inspired by it or
no for me it is actually
that the watering can principle
I founded a foundation almost 20 years
ago and put a lot of money
into it to generate a stock and then from the
proceeds
to be able to do non-profit work accordingly
and I actually
proceed in a relatively unstructured way whenever we come across something that I consider worthy of support or, where necessary, something
particularly big,
I then take care of it, which
then leads to 100 others
arriving and they and you are  then
frustrated because you were only able to help in one out of
a hundred
cases, but i
did most of the investing on my
own, for example, and got decent
income from it at the moment it's
more difficult
because i'm only ever allowed to use the income from
this asset  to
do something and is there something best  but
what you can call names, so to speak, you are
involved, we know
how important they are, of course, there are
many things
that have to do with monument protection in the Potsdam area, but they
also have a lot
to do with social projects that some people
need  5,000 others 10,000 others
only 1,000 and
there are hundreds of
projects that have come together in the meantime
so much to have to go back to
business things gase kintopp the
dax board members of course have now seen
many people come and go, so to speak,
in various jobs there  it in the
german entrepreneur or also his
board members who maybe particularly
impressed you now a hop or
the healer or a hoeneß on the
route or in the way of thinking not
any people said wow that
seemed to me a completely different league
from what he can do like that
economically, yes, it was
always fun with hoeneß, especially about
wi  he was well versed in entertaining economic things
and
with fc bayern he also had a great company
there
we also bickered and fell out in between
but it was actually always
that he made it fun and that was fruitful of course i miss it in
the end  so the really
big perspective i have for
example a retina reuter who used
to be head of daimler benz with whom i was
often exchanged were very
impressive whether he actually led the value of
the
mercedes sensibly into the future
in
retrospect difficult to say because
schrempp  who came later it
was basically the
same for him then
his successor was also a good guy who
then performed with sneakers and his
bandmate
who we also
got along well with but the respective
successors always
carefully hint that they are heavy
burdens  would have taken over and you now
first have to restructure again
insofar  rn I also miss the last
overview of who was really
brilliant and who maybe
not and at all, so to speak,
partner companies if you do it yourself
as rtl is in part far more than you
, so some colleagues have already
started running in the middle
now, yes  she got along well
with middelhoff i have i often
got along well with him
also always with liz mohn and
that was of course
interesting with middelhoff it was of
course super interesting
to see
how the whole thing developed, he also
read it afterwards himself
Written what mistakes he
made and how they took off He
maybe partly there I
don't know if you have to be if you
partly have to be able to
assert yourself I my
middelhoff yes the bertelsmann
brought in an incredible amount of money in that
they sold at that time
where
bertelsmann, contrary
to middelhoff's advice, had very
little m  ittel on attac is joining aol 30
then they only have i have
five then they only had and
i think that was sold again for as much money
as bertelsmann's
total profit since the second world war
so in that
respect the publishing house was of
course really right too  brought forward
but that's how
biographies succeed and some break then
some
overdo some things others are lucky
again to pull themselves out of any developments in time it
's a very colorful world okay
but his motto what have regular
contact probably doesn't even exist
around yes the  who are like that twice a
year and then i see further does not go
with me the latest
balance sheet figures from bertelsmann bkk people
have to say to them that he is
glad he got the money, so to speak,
but the financiers themselves see the
managers a lot of prizes  is the head of
europe you
have with them and
even me with m  The contact
was also
interesting to see during the negotiation. They weren't
young, some of these people weren't even 30
years old, they had a
great education, they had degrees,
etc., and then they came across to
you and you're amazed at what they have on
their screens,
how clever  who can also tactic
how to
completely hide the emotions in such
a process where you, if you have
yourself, think like you did when you were 27 28 years old, yes, you
were quite professionally
experienced because I just started when I was 20
, but that you say
hello to yourself  either they have put up
a good façade or there is
really substance behind it one of the
colleagues and is talking about it on the
supervisory board hesitating so the very young
woman in her early 30s jump yes well
those are really interesting biographies
that you
always see anyway with the  Whole
consulting companies who would love to have
24-25 year olds if possible with a
doctorate under v  then they
should work 100 hours a
week for several years of course earning
really good money and
at 40 the stations are
then that’s the fewest there still discover
again very shortly before we can really
conclude that now believe in the vision
it's difficult to say from ikea, but
you've sold the company anyway,
but do you think that something like
netflix and now disney plus and
that that's the future of television
i can't really say you have to
see it, of course people want to see it  always be
entertained of course you will
always watch something
listen to something but how quickly you will either get
tired of any platforms
i can't say at the moment
you are also seeing
a crazy rollback in the direction of
ard/zdf
public service pictures will
plasberg in the corona crisis  tagesschau heute heute-journal
claus kleber so you suddenly notice that
hey it's getting kind of tight why are
you walking over there why don't you find out more about facebook or
instagram how how things
are going what i actually
no longer believe in is an
amazing renaissance of the printed word so
i notice
how, for example mine  daughters between
20 and 30 there is a real
reluctance to touch something printed
at all and to
deal with the haptics with the cumbersome time of turning the page and laying it
somewhere and getting it from somewhere and
leaving it somewhere in the evening
but the
user interfaces are
clearly digital and  that's why it's going to be
difficult books still sell quite well, interestingly enough, to
what extent they are actually
read is another
question in the podcast, you listen to it as a podcast,
yes, i
hear i hear it from time to time
, that's what used to be called an
interview,
and that's in the  essential or sometimes
at least  yes i do before all
things on longer car journeys how many
podcast offer had already after
and oh yes countless so i should
i should every every week i should like
three to five podcasts please follow
that many i dont have to but also
own  to start formats that yes there was
also the possibility
there was an idea that we get together with
fernsehen nasen and
practically always write letters to
each other so we tell something and the
next one then reacts to it and
then the next one reacts to it again until  it's
because she only comes
back to us in four or five weeks but i take a look at
the fixed
commitments so that i know but
now comes back with weeks and i have to come up with something
like i used to always turn
down columns so  even if i knew
every tuesday I published it and
now it's already
sunday afternoon and the
music will go on until monday morning  I just have this this
pressure that I can withstand on television
as far as regular broadcasts are concerned,
but with everything that is so wrong,
not so well
maybe one more word because of how the corona
crisis reacted. They had
at least spontaneously tried
this quarantine with colleagues Gottschalk &
Pocher  how does it go and
5 million euros i would watched is
in rheine one at the beginning at the
beginning once 3.3 million people
watched and then
it all fell into place straight away that you have to say quite
simply and honestly
nobody needs the show at that
point in time
that was just the really serious
outbreak of the corona crisis in
germany, the country was divided in two,
some only wanted to have an
effect on the topic and that led to
the insane audience ratings in
public broadcasters and the
others wanted to get away from this crisis  and
wanted to be entertained 100 percent
example then do f  looked
inger and what we did in
between this in-between thing
but we are also in quarantine
we didn't get any toilet paper in the
supermarket etc
and at the same time
to tell about our own state of mind
that this central location actually
didn't interest anyone
we were very interested  quickly noticed and very
quickly we contacted the broadcaster
and then said we believe that this is
not productive and that we
should discontinue this project sooner rather than later i think it is always very
good when you dare something, when you try something
new, when you do it  starts and
when you notice that even with
certain improvements the project
cannot be saved, then you
quickly distance yourself from it the
most difficult thing was actually
we were the quarantine flat share when you are in the flat
share you sit at a
table one interrupts the other
word quickly gives up the other in
that everyone  sitting on his laptop
they always had this three second
delay that means they always made
excuses for the others then the
other two started immediately at the same time
then they heard it with a delay
thomas please you said yes you had
something incredibly cs sluggish about it and it
corresponded to that  not at all a
lively back and forth
exchange of ideas at the kitchen table in a flat share but it is
interesting that is so quickly the
feeling went from the outside that i am
not a tv
expert now that tv think about very long cycles and produced for a
long time the program is
changed and there is a new situation that
was good carried big names
but that was that was also great that
rtl went along with it straight away the idea
was clearly developed in our
company but
people didn’t want to discuss it
and I think that’s a good thing that
we quickly figured it out  reacts the cycles are
completely different today, in the past
you unfortunately had annual contracts with
d  three-year contracts were signed and
then they had to pick up the broadcasts as the station is
now almost nothing
piloted anymore my entire
show used to be recorded then all the
people who watched behind the
scenes said yes we can go on the
air with it and then it was
produced today  if africa no longer has any money, it goes
straight to the station
and if it basically doesn’t
work right away it’s gone that’s a shame
because there are of course many examples
of programs that didn’t work at the beginning
and then went through the
roof gzsz is to
example didn't work great at the beginning
who wants to be a millionaire first
show bad rate second show
very bad rate third show
again bad rate and only in the
fourth show a really good rate
if you had given up after three shows
it would have been
practically never whether you  she's okay
so in the end it's even if we
sew again  he at least what has shaped the last few
years very strongly there
is still something like that so if this
brand wants to understand Günther Jauch how
you appear there because we have been
following a certain logic for years
so by the way we are the first guests  offered
the i sieze and but i read
that there are always people besides thomas
gottschalk and children sitting there yes that's why
i will never dare so i
didn't want to at all it is so special that he
obviously has a brand
characteristic of you this
summer too you are 64 now  did you
say anyway the old one the impression
even now in personal encounters
is totally
somehow so youthful a certain
skepticism towards the world but also
an openness to say where to consciously
consider these are my brand values
ave never had any adviser eithe
I've never had a manager in my life either. I've never had a
café like that either. Contact my  office
but I have always knitted everything myself
I know that this is the old
economy and that something like this is
not normal today every influenza with more
than 3000 has already soon lost
88 managers who
take care of him and and and
33 masks  houses and and and five
press spokesmen
and I don't have all that
on the one hand it saved me a lot of work on
the other hand if
you take care of all the nonsense
it will eventually become
annoying and of
course it will also take time but
overall I'm with it  really
strange
old-fashioned the attitude which i
basically can't really
recommend anymore but i personally
rode it quite well i
ultimately always kept control with
it and
and but you have to be that way
anyway so it looks that's
yes  first of
all, that's also atypical for the time, actually, i wanted everything to be
good, i was myself,
yes, i don't do it  because i have this
distinction, this differentiation,
that you can build up a closeness to people
or have a closeness if
you use the familiar name and show a distance
if you sit with them without
it being a devaluation or
meant in a negative way i actually find it
it's nice that there are
these
differentiation possibilities in German, you
can't do that in English
and I
've somehow gotten used
to it  it's not a strategy so i
've never acted
that strategically so i'm now two more
pos but you should join me on
friday when the people come home
and then maybe push again on sunday evening
so all these
considerations are relative to me  foreign ok
check what happens to your data
i saw in hamburg in the neighborhood
there is a shortage  en year is
günther jauch yes i know that because i had
relatives in hamburg who
told me it must be a crash
pub it is totally we were a
little bit better so i have there
is really a
short play here and that is yes  actually got so
far and i wanted to take a
family trip there and then
i wanted to surprise everyone, so to speak,
and we should go there and that's exactly
where the pub
was closed, it was a shame so i stood there in front of the locked door
and then i thought  yes
we'll have to catch up on that then i think
only the golden glove is crazy
it's kind of related now it's
so similar and has a similar location there
but we'll just do it i think
it's possible because the
operator's name is  I really think I
had also let the first yes yes
yes no problem at all I always thought it was
great and I had to go there
stop by there were other
things that had happened to your name
that it wasn't so great that's
crazy yes it's been
heard of course yes bitcoin is certainly bitter
but people keep
trying to
say something about me
or that some product
found me particularly good and then they just try to use
me for advertising
,
which can actually
end badly, so it is actually the case
that the Günther Jauch brand
legally exists, that means if
someone uses this brand in any way
, you can take legal
action against it  having it checked up
to very bitter damages
can count so you should be
careful if you
try to use my name for commercial purposes in any way
that could get expensive for
how long so the typical question now
a bit in closing do you still want to do it
yes  of course the woman has to
come and what will happen then
comes at the end of life
i think is clear to most people
but i really don't have any
big plans the only thing i
actually do
more and more as the compass of my life
is that i think about what i feel like doing, what i
enjoy and what i
don't  I'm more than happy to
do things I
don't really feel like doing anymore
I don't know how long it will last
depends on my
physical and mental
health first of all I certainly won't
younger on the other hand
the little zippers stay within manageable
limits
and
java nothing to do with who wants to be a millionaire on
higher i don't know i
kept that very open
because i don't have a contract with rtl just
a handshake contract and could every
year  we simply have to
renew ourselves by looking into each other's eyes and having to
worry. the se would like to continue
Would you like the spectators
yes I would just like to
continue but if so who wants to be a millionaire
that is for you then it would also be
economically all of that would no longer be
necessary but we still want to donate the money
would be it would be yes that
's fine  a larger sum such an evening
with günther jauch he already brings in
a seven-digit sum on rtl
i don't know what the rtl show
costs in total but i am very
confident that for rtl the
last 20 years or so 1 will not only be
successful with the audience  also a
very lucrative is a typical
günther jauch formulate i am very
confident that it has now been
what about the topic of politics
you are now
extremely credible extremely linked and
networked experience if it were
n’t in the topic that you had to say
there  we react yes many
said
let yourself be lined up or
see if you come here in the  une
can do anything or even
nationally
our political system in germany
is designed so that you
should not only feel you belong to a party
but should also be a
member i
actually have a problem with that i
don't see any party that i belong to
flying flags could overflow because
they correspond to let's say 90 percent of my
political, human,
economic
ideas that simply
don't exist and i do
n't think it's worth submitting to such a stable
order and out of consideration for
any delegates and colleagues
and people in the party the for
are important to me and the employee wing
and please also think of those who are
committed to the church
to go this arduous path that i think is
hard for me to imagine because i
am actually impatient very often
and
then it is very difficult to make
compromises with me  do and so on  Eg
I would feel uncomfortable there
I would say at some point people
leave me alone I'm
out there and
that frustrated
everyone in the end the voters the party myself and in
that respect everyone is all things
where you are  must be insanely able and
willing to compromise these
heavy how do you have to be
in life for the next few days during the
shutdown that Günther jauch imagines
so there are also few opportunities
to work really classically even
now so really now netflix subscription
city be completed  you
still don't have it there
but that's why i have it there but
the plus subscription know everything through in
i use i actually use it
relatively little but i have so much to
work through so much to sort so
much to
put in order that we  really
not a single second is boring what
i'm actually enjoying at the moment
is that i'm not  I have to drive back and forth all the time
or fly but that
I can be at home I like being
at home
I have Sunday almost every day,
not even Saturday again I
also bring structure to my
days but I really have I
really have enough  do everything you
have left behind what you have to sort out
the car that is in some
garage that hasn't started for two years
where you
always have to take care of it
all these things like other people are now
flooding the hardware stores around everything at home
to put things in order that's how it is for
me with many things
to read something that explains what longer i
'm always one of those people who put everything in a
heap that you
really want to read again and if he then
a meter  When I reach 40 I'm
frustrated and usually half gone again
but that's
what I have time for now and what I actually
enjoy okay okay everything  of course many
many thanks that we could speak between
the original may come the
second podcast i only
found one and there were already gourmets
from you that can so
look where you were in the podcast
i could have led something in advance with so
much light there  That's right, I'm there, I
'm a bit behind
there, too, thank you very much for being able to do it, and I
'm glad to
be healthy
current home office pressure and zoom and
max flex and all hold up how it
is to have the customer us army and whether
the whole cell phone tracking
really works if
someone knows then at the end a colleague should go straight
into the conversation and alexa
[music]
Actually, we would have planned completely different things together in a few weeks
and I've already had
several of them here in the last few
weeks  Mention dcast and you'll
get where before that is one of our
most important partners we've been
on the road together
for a few months now the ceo hannes ametsreiter was
here in the podcast a few weeks ago and in may
we wanted to have a really
big hit together several thousand
was shared by colleagues with partners  and
customers will have been with us, as is well known, that wo
n't happen now,
but I thought to myself, I'll call
you alex foul, alex is
managing director in the business-to-business
area at vodafone and hear
how he's doing at least and how he is  just keeps the
store together or so sums up our
whole country you could say
at least in terms of bandwidth and in
general briefly into the partner update in
the quiet man alex yes my breasts you
are reasonably safe in hobart is
namely a yes I'm always on top that
exactly and enjoy  here we
are that's okay all vodafone
know it again yes all vodafone  e so we
have issued a clear policy that
we strive for 100 percent home office
but of course there are always
his activities but in technology
or something like that of course there has to be a
move but in principle you
know the shop is just out of the pipe
and you  don't have to make it clear to
you you have how many employees
in a school and in the organization
i'll say depending on how the cs
between 1,300 and almost 3000 yes ok
but there are also some representatives there
a list no me on the street too
its yes, that's exactly how it can be said, roughly
over the thumb almost 1000 are in sales
and they are now more
on the phone or more digitally
than in the car, exactly, so they
live a bit like our
service worlds because they basically do it
almost only video calls yes and and
also the phone calls below of course
logically and there should also
be one or the other case where
it is  still make customer visits but these
are of course the city under the
specified hygiene rules that you
then
naturally give yourself and
now we are a bit
all the stories that you hear the
network is at the capacity limit switch down
netflix and switch youtubes to
or  clinic one same the
resolution, so to speak, or
speeds you can the update
team
yes I can do that so that
's it for the first time is like this this
one saw netflix and youtube resolution
down switch history that came from
the european commission that
not the us network operator at all  from our
side in Germany somehow pushes
or something because one thing is clear,
different people can say clearly that
our networks can call up the increased volume and
that is of course higher because there's no
question about the increased volume
that's probably true but
like that  magazine for all our
market companions in germany  and but
only with a number like that we already had
and sometimes more than 50 percent of
data traffic is now something of course
okay, so 50
percent of top, so to speak, yes exactly they
have to imagine it that way or
utilization utilization was
not the last time  dimensioned for for a
specific time but ultimately it has
to intercept the peak we
usually regulate at normal times somewhere
between 5 p.m. and 8
p.m  many companies
and people just sit in the home office
or does the curve shift a
bit more into the daytime in
the daytime area and simply because of the
utilization of the network and but that's what it
's staged yes so it's not a we
have  no problem at the moment
we honestly don't see any problems
coming and what was that was the calculation
of the eu  so why did the
desired yes behind round so i think it was
a little bit the international
european approach so
they looked less at individual
european markets we
said more we have to look at the
whole of europe that there is
enough capacity in the networks  there
and now i don't
want to praise the german networks like crazy but we
are a technical people and i would
say that our network, like us
, has criticism that comes up again and again
that may well be true
that we actually have quite good and
that it is a precautionary measure for all
European and tell me because
you generally have more business so we’re
talking about a vodafone b2b here now i
can imagine
many companies are not
so prepared for the home office
because nobody has one because they don’t have one  permanently
installed computer somewhere
and a private mobile phone and a phone call
at the place of the can e  r right is the
home office
but something like that you read there but people suddenly sign up for
new contracts or we
have to introduce them now well that has to
differentiate a bit according to
segments i mean with the i would
say with the really big customers
medium-sized companies  large German customers,
large companies, but above all also
with public clients, i.e. with
the authorities, for example, we are
already seeing a somewhat increased demand in the short term,
so there is a
question about associations of
short-term, very fast bandwidth
increases for additional service
telephone numbers  have to be switched
to
hotlines and so on and so forth so
that's already that's already there yes and of
course we try to help
as best we can and we
have also very specifically
reduced
and accelerated our connection processes  of something,
i.e. an increase in bandwidth takes
about n  After that what more
bandwidth that is but I'll say about
the big thumbs about three weeks
and here particularly systemically important
customers such a process was launched
where we can currently do it in less than 24 hours
I know it myself
here in the office  I
your children your products are a
bit like this cube you have
anyway what do I
imagine now get them now
hundreds of people have to put in such a coup here to have a
network somewhere for which none was
necessary now  there is no addition
business.de is just that we have that's
the way it is, yes we also have we also have
major customers who,
as I said, like to place large orders for their employees
from these computers the product and
then of course gave it to the
employees at home  so that
the corresponding mains supply at home
can be normal if you now
imagine what is normal under
normal conditions  actually
your top product is meeting at 2 if you
talk about bibi again and i also
tell you we work together
then many have the feeling yes ok where of it
i know now from the b to c area
but in the vip area what is what
you then press yours, so to speak, with which you
open the door is
yes that there is not one product
that me yes yes also that that is a
bit special with like tobi because of course we are
in the public
eye let's say behind the colorful advertising messages about my private
customers colleagues  a little bit of
submerging perception, so to speak,
but that’s also completely okay because we’re
just a very solution-oriented state
and also have individual business
, yes, in medium-sized companies, I can’t
really say that there is now exactly
one product that I open the door
with  it's always totally out in the world, always
totally individual depending on what the very
specific challenges are, in
normal times, quite the norm  ale concrete
challenge to the
medium-sized customers is also the hero,
for example
, a
company needs a fiber optic connection so calls a corporate
network for its connection of its
locations that might also be a good
solution because it might be an internet of things
solution because it might soon
be optimizing its own processes for its products
but maybe because he
also wants to optimize his own products with an id
solution, he might also need a cloud security solution
in which to market cloud products and solutions
that might
just be a completely normal, classic
mobile phone, so there
are endless possibilities, that's what
makes them  strengthen and above
all the individualization of
our offers for these customers you have to
say yes but now it has been a couple of
times i need meetings with him
we are internal meetings a thing
without now hopefully planning too much
which somehow fasci
But there was also a group of customers
that I would never have thought of, so you are,
so to speak, partners of large US
bases or of the
German armed forces in general, so what I thought, okay, they
also need your services in the end, of
course, and then there
is  own networks and
so i then take them of course
ok i never thought
they're crazy we have we have a
colorful bouquet through the entire
society and the entire industry
and organizational structures from all over
germany yes but then each one for
himself  of course
we try
absolutely with you is a
bit of the topic that i have also talked about here in the
podcast again and again the
topic 5g
is falling is that a bit down especially
in the current situation or
are priorities changing or say
briefly with the update and yes, well,
to be honest, I mean you have to, you have to
yes the church in the village must also
be honest and honesty is
very clear that at the moment the focus is actually
number one one with an asterisk yes
that we keep our services
running and that's what we do and that we
offer our customers when they stop in their
normal standard
business quotes constant
challenges or issues
that we support you as best we can
somehow and and and
then also provide the solution for
you accordingly of course it is so
that in the background we continue to
work on 5g that will also happen
at some point  the crisis will be over
and it will probably soon be at the
top again and also in the press
in public but 5g is
certainly also in the perception at the moment
will be background suppressed in
public and we will of
course continue to work but as I said that  is
n't 1 at the moment and stands
then I'll get it somehow
somehow  fighting again cases
tells
there are also cases in
football stadiums that
are unthinkable right now and otherwise it was
very brief so that we
talked about it at least once and
not that here I did
n't consciously intend to ask as a question
we didn't talk about what's
the 5d case
that's vulnerable to you is
kind of the one that opens your eyes 5 the
kest par excellence also just all guests given a
little more to the sport task
but i think now spontaneously mine
in my moth box in the back of my head and
although
the last case we are going to have released
big now before
this cola discussion had overshadowed
everything was with the lufthansa in hamburg
even the technology you have to
introduce each aircraft is individual
yes so you think it's the same
type but for everyone for  every plane
has its own parts list documented down to the last
detail and
me of course  me and when these aircraft were
serviced,
this one parts list with
every screw or rivet had to be pulled out individually
and then processed under the
and this exchange of this
data was probably always
very time-consuming in the past and also because the
bandwidth was very slow  was and and that
's just with five go much
faster now and the air are very
happy with it and how you can of course
also perkins happy with
yes okay whatever there is then
hopefully soon we'll
be able to take care of such cases more and
You really do, too, you can feel
a little bit in this example that
make the world better or
faster, easier and
that the topic of corona is getting through you are
actually also on
the mountain with sammer asked you are also in
all these considerations  involved
that there should now be apps where
you can track x tekken, so to speak  n where
do people go to fight the
pandemic and
to use data to understand what is
happening right now are the thing that we
will also discuss with you yes of course there
will also be discussions and I am now
personally but not in the
development of this  app involved but of
course there is this discussion must of
course and with this kind of basic
developed app also say that
the know-how of the provider
includes that is also left as
is is also mixed up you
can't just go through the
order on mobile phone masts  somehow determine to the
meter exactly where
the individual person is now walking and
belonging to life where any but
use has come too close or something
that depends on how you are where
you are in the city almost only
below 30 40 50 meters and if
you on  the country up to a few
kilometers that's just difficult and
that's why you have to get around them  kind of
other but additional elements have
to be installed as well, such as a
bluetooth connection something so
brittig louis to raise this measurement accuracy
to a level that
you really use it if
you want to use it everything is voluntary
and that’s a good thing  it's ok ok
is a forgiving view then
you think you're back to normal
business it's kinda there
but actually internal
estimation that's of
course everything is a total crystal ball
and and the question is i think so
normal business in the sense of normal
this hotel  crisis was that we don't think we want to have
anymore because I
have my my personal thesis but
that's my personal thesis veto
not because it's clear that we're
certainly now so short-term that
places in three phases model yes we
have so now short-term are already
like that  a bit of a boost there again
the bandwidth the seizures  is
asked and since the fire has to be extinguished somehow at short notice
because somewhere something has to be
built quickly and then has to be solved
for customers that is but in a short
phase three four weeks
then that
will have helped and we will certainly be like that for a few
months  experience that many
projects that were planned in the last
financial year or in the last rock or
time so I say
stop by large companies or even
some medium-sized companies
that they were postponed, of course they want to be
postponed now because the
patients of course all say
or many were postponed  say of
course i have different
problems right now than here so to
evaluate and to do that this
shift will still be
felt now for the next three four five
months but then i think so too and
then the third phase will come at some point
every company and every
authority will  and every organization or
lessons learned from  oversized kroner
do these and there will certainly be a
realization somewhere at the
end of these lessons learned that
you should have easily invested more in your digital
infrastructure in the
past i wanted home office
equipment for the employees
keyword bandwidth keyword
mobile communications whatever yes and me  I can
very well imagine that, with a
considerable delay, we will perhaps
experience increased demand in 6 6 months plus, since then there will
soon be many people saying we
have to rework it now,
so I hope we will continue to
exchange ideas or I mean we will
share our common  projects i think we are
working right now you can also
say that hopefully in 20 21 we will
be together
we have to make up for something
that has now been
lost but that it is not
the biggest problem just as a
prospect
and certainly also for autumn i  is
another joint project of
vodafone to see more and then
maybe there will be the next update of
your podcast if you feel like it so in
the sense that they also stop every store
together and and
meet a little thanks philipp thank you and yes you
and yours  team stays your healthy
sleep
short note on my own behalf i
am proud of our academy as our
e-learning offer there runs from the 21st of
the course and google ads fundamentals
so learn how google works for
you there campaign on which switches that
was really a new one  world opens
up you understand so much more about
digital business and digital
marketing once you learn how google really
works feel free to
send your people in there we are
currently offering home office tickets so if
you register now for the
course at the end of may  then there is a 25 percent
discount on the original price my
there is a certificate that lasts
about ten weeks with two
to three hours of learning per week
after that you really got new insights and above
all understood google
strategically and also cooperatively
[music]